الشوارع الخاليه
المكاتب الهجينه المطارات المقيده
سيناريوهات تعيد الى الاذهان ذكريات لم
يتجاوزها كثيرون حتى الان والعالم لن
يتحمل مسيلاتها مره اخرى حسب خبراء
تدابير لا يريد الكثير من الناس التفكير
بها ولكن الاجراءات التي فرضتها بعض دول
العالم على القادمين من الصين اخيرا
اعادتها الى الواجهه الصين بدورها هددت
بتدابير مضاد
كنت هون لي شانشميتي مستعدون للتواصل مع
العالم للتغلب على رائحه كورونا ولكننا
نعتقد ان قيود الدخول التي فرضتها بعض
الدول على الصين تفتقر الى الاساس العلمي
لاتحاد الدولي للنقل الى التعليم
البيت الابيض يرى بدوره ان هذه الاجراءات
مجرد احتياطات لحمايه المواطنين وهي مبنيه
على قواعد الصحه العامه
واتخذت بعد استشارات مع خبراء من عده دول
اجراءات اختبرها العالم
لثلاث سنوات مضت بين ان الانظمه الصحيه
والاقتصاديه تعلمت من هذه التجارب واصبحت
اكثر خبره في التعامل مع هذه الانواع من
الازمات وفق ما يرى خبراء الصحه والاقتصاد
وتتحدث عنه الدراسات التي اجريت بعد ان
ضربت الجائحه انظمه واقتصادات الدول في
مقتل